Pokemon go is life at least for the
millions of players who swarm the mobile
games since its launch while developer
Niantic plans on making the game more
robust balanced and stable much of the
game hasn't met players high
expectations easy prey one of the most
important parts of Pokemon is the
ability to battle wild pokémon while
Pokemon Go allows users to wander around
and go find a gas leak there's really no
fighting involved instead capturing wild
Pocket Monsters has become a game of
ring-toss by bouncing a pokeball off a
circle surrounding your prey you can
attempt to capture it's like an abridged
version of a real Pokemon experience
rural ruminations Pokemon go is catered
to players in populated and tech-savvy
areas because it's essentially a reskin
of my antics previous game ingress every
polka stop is a place which ingress
players had previously marked if you
live in a small town your local game
probably won't have many stops none of
this really fits Pokemon wear trainers
spend most of their time in forest with
an occasional visit to a small town or
gym granted wandering through the wife
eyeless woods to play a mobile game
isn't really safe but for now Pokemon go
remains a game optimized for city folk
terrible tech if your phone isn't the
newest model or it's slightly cloudy or
you're stuck in an overloaded server
goes location services have been shady
players have spent days on end waiting
for their game to maintain a consistent
connection even worse you finally find a
distant polka stop and you inexplicably
lose your GPS signal it's enough to make
you want to stomp an oddish and those
guys are adorable pay to play because
Pokemon go is a mobile app micro
transactions are expected but because
it's an actively competitive mobile app
those with cash can quickly rise to the
top while the Warriors are an issue with
just about every multiplayer online game
made for smartphones but Pokemon is a
property that's basically intended for
kids putting a paywall in front of a
little aspiring Ash Ketchum just feels
nasty lousy launch Niantic servers just
can't handle the apps traffic games
sometimes freeze immediately after
important captures if you can log on at
all while portions of the app have
smoothed out there are still plenty of
aspects that simply don't work
consistently enough to offer a truly
enjoyable experience everything still
feels like it's in beta mode but the
future still looks exciting hack a mom
as with any competitive app there are
already cheaters out there within days
of release it was easy to find
helping players obtain endless currency
level up their Pokemon without any
effort and visit local gyms without ever
leaving their bathroom one would hope
that the moral lessons of Pokemon would
somehow carry over into the real world
Pokemon go etiquette but as long as
there are people out there who can't be
trusted they'll always be disappointment
and distrust thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what disappointed you in Pokemon go